we are collecting around 300 data points
coming in on each patient then they go
to the doctor and they're shocked my
doctor can't understand it the tumors
shrinking you want to have people
running a clinical trial that do not
have skin in the game on the product and
you're saying CBD only is all that's
needed because that's the medicine
because it's just not true the whole
plant is the medicine when I saw what
this medicine could do my first reaction
was I was angry that nobody had told me
this and I'd been fed of a bunch of Lies
all these years what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Don
sock young we are still at the new West
Summit the world's leading cannabis tech
conference we are now sitting down with
Mara Gordon thank you for joining us
thank you so much for having me I'm
happy to be here I'm really happy that I
had the opportunity to introduce you as
an emcee and then your panel which is
really interesting on CBDs we're gonna
get to that that's a very fascinating
cannabinoid that we need to talk about
and unpack more so interesting you were
also teaching we were walking with our
friend Conrad and you were teaching us
about all of the important data that
you've acquired on cannabis and on
clinical trial on efficacy on like
milligram dosage and what it all this
kind of stuff so important especially
for people that are you know trying what
is five milligrams do for me what does
10 do what does 15 do how do these the
differences so why don't you tell us
about yourself and about all that you
know data that we'll start there okay so
I'm gonna back just a little bit up to
say I like what I told you on the way
here talking about how all this came to
be and when I first came to this
industry I was just horrified about
eight years ago about what the options
were for products to be used by people
who were not necessarily looking to use
it to get high but we're using it in
order
to think of it in terms of to alleviate
some sort of a health issue or a life
problem which is there's a different
approach to it and so when I started
looking at the products that were
available and looking at the information
associated with them the engineer and me
came out and said well I can do better
and I said well you know I'm going to
focus on just solving the dosing
conundrum because once we solve that we
will then be able to get adoption of
this from the medical community from
mainstream and to eliminate some of the
fear so it was all about education and
understanding what's in the medicine as
soon as there was lab testing available
in the state of California we were like
customer number two standing in line to
be doing lab testing there are issues
around that and I've come to find that
you know we have to you know make some
modifications you know on the confidence
level on some of the data points but the
first thing I did was say okay what are
the questions that we want to ask that
we want to ask we want to find out about
so that we can learn where the patterns
are and I think of it in terms of
anybody who's ever hung wallpaper and I
know it's a strange analogy but if
you've ever hung wallpaper you know it
might have a 5 inch repeat it might be
an 18 inch repeat it may whatever so
where is it gonna be where we're gonna
have enough information about a
particular thing to know whether it's
applicable so one of the problems for
example with a lot of the anecdotal data
that's out there I should say the
antidote of stories that are out there
is there an N of one there might be a
million ends of one but each one of them
is only that there are some things that
we can extrapolate through observational
studies and asking certain questions but
there's they're not all consistently
asking the right questions whatever
there's not only no one quite in the
world like you because you're unique in
all your experiences led you to that
point but then also we have to quantify
our experiences very logically as well
subjectively in order to be
able to have it as raw data input into a
database exactly so we are collecting
around 300 data points coming in on each
patient per per patient per use as well
no no per patient so what we do is we've
been setting up for example we're
collecting all of the same information
that you that you would be giving to any
healthcare professional
specialist so if you think in terms of
you blow out your knee and you go to
need to go to a neurosurgeon they're
gonna hand you a clipboard with 11 or 12
pages of questions or they're gonna
email it to you or mail it and they were
whatever because the hip but they're
probably gonna send it in the post and
you're gonna fill all that out and then
they're gonna either have somebody sit
and re-enter it in or they're gonna scan
it and it's gonna become a PDF and it's
non digitized and it's not really cannot
be then searched and quantified so what
I did was I built a platform where we
actually people can go online and answer
these questions once that we have all of
that information in there we are then
able to based upon some algorithms that
we've created and a bit of machine
learning that's in there look at people
that have been having the same diagnosis
maybe the same age group maybe the same
demographic general area and saying what
have they used how has it worked
etc because what happens is one of these
people they come and they fill out all
that that questionnaire we help set them
up on based upon just scientific data
around the endocannabinoids system which
cannabis is which cannabinoids are going
to activate those receptors which
terpenes have other health benefits etc
and we'll help set them up on a
particular formulation and then help
them to titrate to a point to which it
is achieving the medical benefit or
whatever it is their objective is I
think the key point is that we have each
person who participates they establish
what the objective for example somebody
comes to me with a stage four brain
tumor they
may say I want to let my objective is to
kill the cancer another person with that
same diagnosis might say I just want to
deal with the side effects of
chemotherapy or I just want to be
comfortable until I die
and we respect them and honor them and
meet them wherever they are because it's
their right not ours so that would go
into the data though so let's say we set
them up on you know 10 milligrams a day
of THC and 20 milligrams of CBD I'm just
making this up out of nowhere hopefully
they know it's an option though if
they're at least educated that it's an
option that they can potentially kill
the brain tumor and live lo and behold
what ends up happening is it starts
working and you know then they go to the
doctor and they're shocked my doctor
can't understand it that the tumors
shrinking they don't understand it
there's no reason why and we're like you
know well you know that's we know it
works in a petri dish we know it works
in mice models we know it were that a
lot of anecdotal around it but you know
we still haven't done the the clinical
in the cancer we're working on it by the
way
so once let's say this person is given
their suggested starting titration to a
certain point we then will which which
can happen is it's I'm just I'm just
pulling one out of the air yeah I'm just
saying let's say somebody comes and
they're saying they're having sleep
issues for example we're doing actual
clinical trials now double-blind
clinical trials down in Australia right
now for sleep for insomnia so I'm gonna
quit and use it as an example so let's
say they we're gonna have them on a full
spectrum medicine that has allows the
person to comfortably take to titrate up
to 10 15 milligrams of THC with a full
spectrum that includes things like
mersin and a little wool and other
things that have somnolent benefits as
well within the plant so we'll pick a
profile like that we then have a lab
result associated with that exact
medicine they're using so when they then
use it we're able to then track the
results of it tied to the profile of
that particular
medicine each time they change their
medicine we're able to track as it's
working a little more as it's working a
little less in all of that and then they
go to their doctor and the doctor you
know most diseases have a measurement
whether that measurement is a scale of
where they are on tumor growth and
pediatrics or where it is in adults or
if it's a pain scale I mean we've all
seen the antiquated faces of the all the
way from the happy face to you know the
the one that rather be dead at a level
ten and it's like 'red so they all have
their scales we also have them upload
into our data things like their MRIs
their their medical or their blood work
all of those things so that we're able
to look at not just how they feel but
whether in a metabolic level it's
actually having the benefit that they're
looking for and then we're able to then
repeat it over and over and over again
and then we're able to identify where
the where the the outliers and for
example then we start establishing
patterns you get enough people you start
seeing the patterns back to the
wallpaper example where is it repeat
where is this going on
for example let's ask you what are you
seeing give you a couple of very good
examples especially in the medical space
we have found after treating thousands
of people over all of these years that
there is zero correlation between
milligrams of cannabinoids and kilograms
of weight it does not apply in cannabis
the way it does in pharmaceuticals we're
a pharmaceutical firm most of the first
thing they asked is how much do you
weigh whatever it someone weighs 250
someone weighs 125 in terms of pounds
and then they're each given 20
milligrams that's no effect our if we
actually measure the effect then we
would say it's the same across the
weight we wouldn't say it's the same but
we wouldn't necessarily be able to
equate it to the weight it probably has
a lot more to do with the neuro chemist
biochemistry all this other stuff than
it does have to do then it has to do
with it has to like to do with fact it
has to do with hydration mood it has to
do with propensity for needing to be in
control it has to do with a lot of
things it has to do with the heavy user
versus light user all of these things
one thing that we're we have recognized
a pattern right and especially since the
first thing a doctor wants to do is
figure out milligrams per kilogram and
it's just doesn't work I heard a doctor
whose name I won't mention who
specializes in pediatric seizures say
well it's between five and twenty
milligrams per kill you
I'm right do you have any idea what that
range is that's a meaningless range for
a doctor to prescribe to five to twenty
it's absurd it makes no sense whatsoever
where we have seen patterns is in in the
data is in the dose and the age the
younger the patient the higher the dose
the older the patient the younger the
dose so I may have a yes for for example
I might have a child who's on four
hundred milligrams a day of THC and
they're going to school where where
they're able to tie trace that happens
today their kid that's going through
chemotherapy and has cancer and they're
being treated because yeah and then you
have somebody who has the exact same
diagnosis who's an elderly person and
they may be on 25 milligrams or thirty
milligrams to receive the same result
Wow yeah because we are actually trying
to get somebody to a level of the health
benefit without having them have to have
it interfere with their life you know
I'm on cannabis every single day of my
life and I'm a highly functional highly
effective human being out there and I
don't walk around feeling high because I
take the amount that's necessary in
order for me to achieve the medical
benefit without having to feel altered
now and I take THC primarily I want to
stay on that for just a moment because I
no how many people actually realize that
that is totally possible a lot of people
are trapped in a binary position like
either no cannabis or cannabis and that
means I'm completely altered state of
consciousness and so there is so much
spectrum in between you just described
being able to have a bodily medicinal
benefit meanwhile being still the
productive self in the day-to-day
operations of what you want to achieve
absolutely absolutely 100% if I choose
to take more I'm making a conscious
choice and then I'm moving into a
different realm but as far as the same
way that I get up in the morning and I
take my medicine for my asthma I take my
cannabis and I'm able to function just
just fine now if I'm having a
particularly bad pain day I might have
take a little bit more if the pain is to
a point where it's truly interfering
with my ability to function to think
clearly whatever I may have to take it
to the point where I'm feeling more of
the psycho activity but if I was to
replace that with an opioid I would be
the same thing I would be to the point
where I was nodding and doing all the
things that somebody that's on a heavy
opioid would be doing as well so it's a
much healthier option to get to that
point but when it's taken correctly it
doesn't have to make you feel like
you're walking around stoned all the
time so do we have another trend that
you think's important to talk about as
we move to CBD I think that it's
important that we the trend of
mainstream products going into like the
supermarket's the Whole Foods etc that
are all jumping on this cannabis
bandwagon I think that it's a very
important trend and I think I like it
I'm a little bit leery of the fact that
it's that it's making it more about the
CBD and instead of the whole plant I
actually gave them the give us that
statistic a little bit ago that was 70
yeah about 70 percent of our patients
would not be able to be treated without
tea
hc' yeah so it is a significant
percentage of them and there are about
like I said there's about a third of the
population that when they use CBD they
feel extremely sleepy my husband for
example takes a hundred milligrams of
CBD every night before he goes to bed he
does that because he has some health
issues that it helps with he used to be
you know he's a man of a certain age he
used to be on something for his prostate
now he's being able to get off of all
the pharmaceuticals using this but he
goes to sleep if I take as little as you
know five milligrams of CBD it makes me
feel like I'm jumping out of my skin I
feel activated I feel anxious I feel
uncomfortable and so I don't tend to go
towards the CBD products a lot now part
of that's the entourage effect and what
else is in there but frankly I would
have no interest in an isolate and I
don't think any I mean the panel I just
did there were five people on there
there was only one person who was all
four isolate and that's because you know
to him a hammer is everything's a nail
because that's what they sell so I would
take that with a grain of salt when
that's somebody's product of course
that's what they're for yeah no oh man I
said I feel as though I still want to
stay a tiny bit longer on as you you
know we started moving the CBD but
there's just so much fascination can you
tell us the use of 300 data points per
patient at the beginning usage and and
the follow up and everything on
everything that they use as well how
does a clinical trial like the one
happening in Australia how do they link
up with you for you to put all the data
into your database and then be able to
run the algorithms and machine learning
so I'm not actually running the clinical
trial they are collecting the data here
that's being done by a third-party
independent clinical trial come you want
to have people running a clinical trial
that do not have skin in the game on the
product yeah yes yes that's very very
biased yeah it's a very important point
so what happened was I
patience for years in her I didn't treat
I helped patients with medicine and this
and that for years and years and years
around sleep and was able to look and
see which combination of cannabinoids
and terpenoids and also at what dose
levels of those or quantity of the
cannabinoids I should say that they were
able to use across you know as an
average and then take that data and then
go to Zelda therapeutics which is a
biopharmaceutical company which I just
happened to have found also that's out
of Australia and then through there
because it's public it was able to raise
the money needed to be able to do these
level of trials they then fund the
clinical trial utilizing my formulations
yeah and we filed patents and do all the
things you have to do to you know to
make investors happy so then there is a
the data that you're taking about let's
say my biometrics and then you're also
taking the the can of the cannabinoid
that you're using you're taking the
milligram dosage you're taking if there
is out of terpenes here so then there's
all that data if there's any terpenes
yes yes there's any turkeys to the plant
and it's a very very important
distinction is that we only work with
whole plant whole plant does not mean
the roots in the stems and the all that
whole plant means that whatever the
profile the plant is is what the profile
of the final medicine and not because
we've added artificial to it let's let's
stay here with this point quick so then
the the biometrics then you have the can
of the cannabinoid that you've selected
the the dosage of the milligram the
amount and then there's there's more
data that's being this is all data
that's kind of in your in your in the
soup of experience who that person is
all this kind of stuff so and then the
other thing I wanted to mention was it
then there's what you're targeting it
for what the person wants do they want
to have their seizures and do they want
what do
want with it and then how efficient is
what you're choosing as a cannabinoid
how efficient is it at solving that and
so that whole kind of like trying to
learn that whole that soup that you're
making every time is now being
quantified and it's being measured and
this being that that way you can find
these patterns you can find these
efficiencies thank you for doing that
that's so important honored really I was
I had retired in 2003 and I never
planned on working again I didn't need
to work again I was done and this was
kind of thing that when I saw this and
it was before this huge green rush I
mean you know when I saw what this
medicine could do my first reaction was
I was angry that nobody had told me this
and I'd been fed a bunch of Lies all
these years but then the second thing
was someone's got to figure this out and
I'm smarter than the average bear so I
figured I might as well give it a shot
so I started figuring out first thing we
need to do is educate doctors and nurses
about the endocannabinoids system so I
started a medical practice and started
training doctors and nurses and then I
said and we need to have well-understood
products that they can use and we
understand so I'm gonna start making
these things based upon the profile of
the medicine I'm going to have them lab
tested so that I can know and verify
what's actually in them then I can
record what people are using how many
milligrams of each thing and so I'm
gonna collect all that the ball now I
better build this platform for all this
dating to go into and so then I ended up
with the software and then it was like
okay I'm doing all this so now I'm gonna
validate it with clinical trials so I'm
gonna go create this company and then I
started seeing the latest trends of
going on the industry with this
mass-produced white labeled product
that's pretty low on the totem pole as
far as quality in many cases and you
asked the average person in this space
what their background is and most of
them have a marketing degree and those
are the products that are getting all
the shelf space are being manufactured
by companies that that come from the
let's get the largest market share we
can in this space and tell a good story
and have pretty package and I was like
that's great you keep doing that but
please please at least put something
nice inside of it and so we're the Intel
in the laptop you know yeah so we've
basically so I said I'm gonna start a
company and I call it the oil plant
which makes perfect sense because we
make oil and we make it and we put it
into the enceladus products or we make
we make the aunts eldest products at the
oil plant but we're also making other
people's products and we're also now
providing oil to go into other people's
products either through extraction or
infusion okay and kind of covered in now
yeah and now doing the the merger in
with the oil plant with Gabriella's
kitchen so now we're doing the full
spectrum for better from you for you
foods that have no infusion all the way
through infused products to the really
serious medicinal type products and this
is again a big spectrum of dosages of
very small amounts to nothing to micro
dosing to macro it's great by phase ik
effect also because something that works
at a low level you know it doesn't work
here and then it works here and then you
say oh I'm going to take a little bit
more it can go back down and not work
anymore so cannabis the cannabinoids in
particular you have to be really careful
of that and then one last point on that
is on the whole plant versus the single
molecule when people use a whole
spectrum a fuller use the biphasic true
for everybody yes yes that's just the
way the plant works yeah which is why
people will smoke themselves sober you
know you get year-round somebody who's
been smoking pot all day they're not
high they don't feel high anymore they
don't feel that psycho activity if they
probably would they felt higher on one
hit then they're gonna feel I'm sitting
and passing a bong around all day yeah
so yeah yeah
um one can become used to the effect
over that's also is the other thing is
you can get to where you need to do some
sort of a of a you know a 48-hour flush
to basically become to reset your
endocannabinoid system otherwise good to
go a whole month of being sober because
then you're like yeah right
we actually after 48 hours it's just
psychological that it's some bigger
reset yeah that's always fun notice that
conscientious agreements with yourself -
yeah somebody from ArcView who's doing
you know a sober october or whatever
they call it yeah yeah it's like no
thank you
I get up take my medicine it's like I'm
gonna say oh no I'm gonna take my asthma
medicine today because it's October I
mean to me it's medicine yeah yeah but
for for people that are just try and do
it as a challenge to them so it's not
kind of stuff now okay speak to us a
little more on the CBD side of things
okay where are we in terms of
understanding you were saying earlier
70% of the cases again that are that are
using they're using cameras that are not
CBD is that what not quite what I said
was 70 percent of the people that we
work with would not be able to be
treated without the presence of THC okay
got it okay 70 percent of the people you
trees so CBG it's also all the other
cannabinoids full-spectrum but you can't
take CBD out alone like for me I know
chronic insomnia 70 percent of the
people you treat are use you're using a
THC cannabinoid in there they're also
using or they may only be using or also
using right so the point is that you
can't just eliminate the THC because
it's not the medicine and just use the
CBD because you're not going to be able
to treat most these things for example
if somebody has a a tumor and you're
trying to target the cb1 receptors okay
to kill the cannabinoids in this
nervous system or something you can
target that with THC quite effectively
and quite simply CBD works it has a
milder affinity and it's not gonna work
quite as well it's gonna work
differently so you can accomplish with
certain diseases some of the same things
but you're not going to have the same of
benefit or the same rate or anything
else if you have somebody who's has
anxiety it might be that a very small
macro micro dose of CBD might be exactly
what they need but it also might not be
what they need and they need the THC to
do it so it's it's unfair to people to
say CBD or nothing and I have such a big
problem with these states and advocates
in our suppose an industry who've gone
around for self-serving purposes and are
saying CBD only is all that's needed
because that's the medicine because it's
just not true good I'm glad you're
speaking that's true the whole plant is
the medicine yeah you're saying that
okay what else should we be aware of
regarding CBD Before we jump into future
I think it's important that when you're
identifying a CBD product that you need
to look at things like where was the
hemp or the cannabis I know that they're
the same so when I say hemp I'm talking
legal farm bill hemp versus cannabis
going through controlled regulated
market so I'm using the terms that way
you need to know how they were grown how
they whether they were tested for all of
the microbials aflatoxin zico toxins all
those things heavy metals pesticides
down to you know very very fine levels
to make sure they're not Nair it's an
accumulator plant so you want to make
sure that you know something that was
used to clean the soil after a nuclear
dump isn't then used to extract CBD to
treat your mother so you need to make
sure you know the
the source and the lifecycle and then
it's been tested it's also important
that there is that entourage effect
because you know this is an example I've
given many many times when I give a
presentation in fact is the entourage
effect as though the rich get richer
type thing no entourage effect in the
sense that the whole is greater than the
sum of its parts
so for example I use an example when I
give presentations quite frequently
where I'll say okay I'm going to make a
chocolate cake so I get out the flour
and the butter and the sugar and the
eggs and the vanilla and all these you
know various ingredients and I put them
on the counter if I eat them one by one
yes I've technically eaten the stuff
that makes the chocolate cake but I have
not had the experience of eating a
chocolate cake like if you went to a
table that had eight powerful people
sitting at it and you went and just
talked to each one of them outside of
the room versus you actually were
sitting at the table with them listening
to how they all converse and about what
they converse I would say I don't know
that that that's a tough one that one
I'm gonna have to say huh no chocolate
cake one was good though yeah yeah I
would say it's more along the lines of
if you take if you take blue and you
take red and you mix them together you
get purple but you can sit blue and red
next to each other and they're not gonna
be purple so I think that's probably a
better way to look at entourage trying
to think about it with like a relatable
example with Network like network Theory
like of people talking right right so I
think it has more to do with the fact
that it's it's about the combining and
the fact that like I said you know the
whole is greater than the sum of its
parts so it's not one plus one is two
it's one plus one might be four yeah so
ok so now we'll dive us into some of the
aspects on the future of cannabis that
you think are just really important to
communicate I think that it's very
important what's happening right now
you have this consolidation of brands in
groups in groupings I'm doing it myself
I'm just guilty of it as everything else
but what I'm doing is I'm identifying
companies that have a similar ethos that
have a similar approach that fits
somewhere along that lifeline from
healthy foods to you know serious
medicines and everything in between
for anything that goes in or on your
body of being of a level of quality and
caring and science behind it versus
going too quick to market hurry up get
as much market share as you can and
worry about the the product the quality
of it later I had a discussion with
Steve Berg who's the I think he's the
CEO of Firefly I had a discussion with
him at a yoga retreat about it a little
over a year ago and he said that it's
like it's like the Ralph Lauren model he
said Ralph Lauren was always a very
exclusive brand it was like you had to
go to the Ralph Lauren store you went to
Neiman's or Nordstrom's and went to the
Ralph Lauren department and it was a big
deal and then they came out with their
chaps line and they were in Kohl's and
everything well what happened was a
rapper was wearing and I don't know who
it was was wearing it's probably Kanye
or something wearing a Ralph Lauren polo
shirt or something in one of his videos
and all of a sudden mainstream started
clamoring around for Ralph Lauren so
they came out with the lower-priced line
and Ken went out and went everywhere
well what happened is they angered their
exclusive customers right who were like
wait a minute
I went from saying oh it's Ralph Lauren
and people going who - now you say Ralph
Lauren and it's like ah you know big
deal and so the fickleness of the mass
market that you know today it's Ralph
Lauren tomorrow it's it's Nike or
whatever they came and went and then
they lost that big market of the other
so that's a that's a decision a company
makes on how they're going to exist as a
company in the marketplace that's a huge
point because we have had so many
discussions now about the way to enter
into markets who are your demographics
that you would like to engage with you
in your product or service that you're
trying to bring to the world it's
important to be very careful with with
understanding what that what that market
is and and what the long-term vision
might be with may be entering secondary
markets exactly and understanding
whether you're going to come in this for
the long haul or the short money and get
out so you have to figure out where you
want to play in this space completely -
you know legitimately have your have
your place in it so I mean I made the
decision early on that I cared about
quality and longevity so I took an R&D
approach I cared more about having deep
knowledge and excellence in
manufacturing and then when the market
started to turn like now I'm ready
because I've got all that data I've got
all that research I know what to put out
there so I don't have to create a big
giant storm of marketing material around
it because it's I know where to go I
know where to meet the consumer because
I'm already there so I think it puts us
at a bit of an advantage I'm not a
marketing or finance or business person
particularly I'm becoming more I have my
whole vocabulary has shifted because of
this some of the questions that I'm
asked I have no idea what they're even
talking about but then again you know
let's start talking in no cannabinoid
system they don't know what I'm talking
about
so it means yeah but I think it's really
important that that we look into who the
people are and what their egos and why
they're in this and what they're doing
in and the companies that are coming
together need to come together with that
common thing because all of them will be
raised together in a much better way you
don't want to have one that's you know
lopsided or one that's going to bring
everybody down
so you have to be very very careful in
who you associate with right now but
like how you're pushing ethics you throw
so has a main pillar of what you're
discussing 100% I mean you know I
operate in a federally illegal business
and I and I say I my if you ever see
weed the people the the a PFG and Ricki
Lake film its following me and several
of my pediatric cancer patients for
about five and a half years talked about
putting myself at the forefront of being
specialized in giving a Schedule one
drug to babies so if I didn't have a
high level of of importance that I put
on values and quality and ethos then I
would be not only in danger of legal
ramifications but more importantly what
I'd be doing to the danger to other
people's lives and there's a
responsibility for those of us that are
in this space now not to go to Facebook
for medical advice not to go to Amazon
or Etsy to buy our our CBD but to
actually treat this as an important drug
or and medicine and food source and not
just a commodity to be pushed as much as
we can out into the market so you can
make a bunch of money and take off yeah
I really appreciate your perspective on
all of that we we talk a lot about
ethics on the show we talk a lot about
the future of humanity we talk a lot
about the trajectory of civilization and
it takes a long time and a lot of
experts and a congregating that are been
that I want to benevolently have
powerful discussion around ideas that
can help get to the public and keep
people safe and inspired and all that
kind of stuff along the way
yeah and reduce suffering all this
amazing stuff so any last thoughts on
the way out I guess I the panel I just
did was way out of my comfort zone but
interesting was all bunch of hemp people
it was like what and why am I here
but but it was interesting
I think that this the last thing is that
there are a lot of studies that are
being done a lot of studies that are
being done right now for example in
Israel everybody points to are being
done on the single molecule
pharmaceutical model that is not the
model that we want to go I am absolutely
not in favor I mean there's exceptions
there's people like David Mary who's
doing full spectrum analysis over at
Technion but I'm we have both like both
individual molecule like isolation but
then also combining as well and
analyzing the results um we can do it in
the petri dishes and things like that in
order to just find mechanisms of action
and what's working etc but I feel like
it's irresponsible the same way Darabont
all or Marinol is responsible to have
that be a drug when it's such an
inferior product to using THC derived
and in in encased within the whole plant
a single molecule is inferior compared
to in fact the study that we just did
that was published a few months back on
the three major subtypes of breast
cancer was comparing the pure compound
to the whole plant and we even went so
far is in the second phase of the study
we looked at taking the top five
terpenes that were in the whole plant
and adding that to the pure compound to
see if that worked and it didn't work
any better so whole plant there's
something in there some things in there
that when they're in combination in the
right ratios they just work better and I
really would I really want people to
understand that this needs to stay can
stay in the biopharmaceutical space and
not get pushed over into Pharma because
it would be an inferior product so
instead of saying well that's the only
way people will get it change the way
people get it instead of settling for
second best that's the real innovation
and the real creativity right there is
to come up with a completely new off
path ways of moving forward I love that
awesome what a pleasure this has been
thank you
so much for coming onto the show thank
you so much so disciplined across you
know data across reducing suffering
helping people CBDs just been really
interesting learning from you thank you
for coming on the show thanks around for
tuning in
also make sure to go create go build go
manifest your destiny and thank you and
we'll see you soon
[Music]